hola bienvenidos nuevamente bueno ya que
así concluimos con todo lo que debes
aprender sobre las reglas o leyes de
ángulos y todo lo que debemos saber para
empezar el juego de el de ángulos así
que bueno sólo te voy a enseñar unos
cuantos unos cuantos reglas más digamos
supongamos que yo tengo aquí dos líneas
entonces tengo aquí dos líneas paralelas
tal vez no tengas idea de lo que es una
línea paralela pero te lo voy a explicar
en este momento ahora tengo una línea
así y bueno aunque tal vez tengas tal
vez si tenés intuición de lo que es una
línea paralela entonces tengo dos líneas
son paralelas aquí asumimos que estas
dos líneas siguen indefinidamente porque
bueno son nociones abstractas cierto
esta línea azul jamás jamás termina y lo
mismo para la línea verde y bueno líneas
paralelas son líneas que están en el
mismo plano un plano puedes verlo como
una superficie plana aunque no
entraremos en detalle de lo que bueno no
vamos a entrar en lo que es un espacio
tridimensional y nada de eso hoy no pero
están en el mismo plano y puedes pensar
en ello como la pantalla de tu
computadora ahora
sus líneas jamás intersectan obviamente
si las dibujamos una sobre la otra
entonces si se intersectan en cada punto
pero bueno estas son simplemente dos
líneas en un plano y jamás se
intersectan son líneas paralelas y ya
bueno ya aprendiste si aprendiste
álgebra y estás familiarizado con la
palabra pendiente líneas paralelas son
líneas que tienen la misma pendiente
incrementando decrementar en la misma
razón pero bueno si no sabes de lo que
hablo ni te preocupes no pasa nada creo
que ya tienes la intuición de lo que es
una línea paralela y bueno ya lo has
visto ya lo has visto por ejemplo
estacionarse paralelamente cuando es
acción es un coche junto a otro coche no
deben interceptar se porque bueno
estaría llamando a la aseguradora
aunque bueno mal chiste pero en fin
estas son líneas paralelas la verde y la
línea azul son líneas paralelas ahora te
voy a introducir a un nuevo término
geométrico llamado una transversal una
transversal es una línea que intersecta
a las otras dos líneas en esta es una
transversal ajá entonces esta es una
transversal y bueno tal vez te pueda
parecer una palabra am algo elegante
pero pero no de hecho
muy sencillo una transversal la voy a
escribir transversal transversal
entonces una línea transversal cruza las
otras dos líneas y bueno en fin
siguiendo con la geometría tenemos que
una transversal una transversal que
intersecta las dos líneas paralelas
y bueno lo que haremos es ok de hecho a
una observación muy interesante si la
transversal intersectan una linea
intersecta a la otra baja porque no hay
manera de que yo dibuje una línea que
intersecta una línea paralela y la a la
otra no por ejemplo bueno eso es
imposible es cierto porque es una
transversal sigue indefinidamente en
ambas direcciones entonces bueno lo que
haremos aquí es es explicar los ángulos
que se forman cuando una transversal
corta a dos líneas que son paralelas lo
que haremos ahora entonces primero que
todo lo que haré es explorar los ángulos
correspondientes ya vimos esto en otro
vídeo baja ángulos correspondientes son
ángulos que están en la misma posición
por así decirlo ahorita me voy a
entender pero por ejemplo mira
ángulo este ángulo y este otro ángulo
son ángulos correspondientes puedes ver
que juegan el mismo papel por así
decirlo cuando la transversal corta las
líneas y como puedes imaginarlo tal como
se ve en mi dibujo que por cierto me
quedo excelente esta vez por lo regular
no pasa eso pero bueno estos ángulos me
dirán lo mismo ajá entonces si éste mide
x también éste mide x y sabemos eso
entonces podemos usar las reglas que ya
aprendimos para averiguar lo demás
acerca de bueno los ángulos que se
forman con respecto a las líneas que
están aquí interceptadas y todo esto así
por ejemplo si éste mide x cuánto va a
medir el ángulo opuesto cuánto mide este
ángulo entonces este ángulo cuánto mide
estos son ángulos opuestos por el
vértice por lo tanto también este ángulo
mide x cierto y análogo para este otro
ángulo
este es el ángulo opuesto para este
ángulo así que también este ángulo mide
aquí son ángulos opuestos por el vértice
ahora
cuánto mide cuánto mide este ángulo voy
a elegir un color un color es de color
amarillo está bien entonces ok cuánto me
dirá este ángulo justo como lo estuvimos
viendo antes tenemos que este enorme
ángulo todo este ángulo mide 180 xy este
ángulo amarillo son ángulos
suplementarios podemos llamar este
ángulo qué te parece ya entonces el
ángulo es igual a 180 grados menos equis
y estamos usando lo que sabemos sobre
ángulos suplementarios si este ángulo es
ye su ángulo opuesto por el vértice
también mide lo mismo también este
ángulo es fascinante no crees ahora
similarmente tenemos que x y este ángulo
que también lo voy a dibujar en amarillo
son ángulos suplementarios entonces
también mide 180 en total así que este
amarillo es 180 menos x es igual a jane
y por lo tanto es un ángulo opuesto
también mide y así que hay muchas hay
muchas palabras de geometría y reglas de
geometría que se están utilizando aquí
un repaso muy rápido pero en cine es
algo muy brillante lo que estoy haciendo
es iniciar con la noción de ángulo
correspondiente dije ok mira este ángulo
mide x y este ángulo mide x son ángulos
correspondientes y ahora si este ángulo
mide x también este porque son ángulos
opuestos por el vértice ahora también
estos estos ángulos en color magenta son
ángulos correspondientes porque bueno
juegan en un papel cierto son los
ángulos inferior izquierdo están en ese
lado y ahora vamos con los ángulos
suplementarios bueno para ver que
también sus ángulos miden lo mismo este
ángulo amarillo es igual a este otro
ángulo amarillo porque son ángulos
correspondientes así que tenemos esa
información ángulos correspondientes son
iguales y tiene sentido lo que yo digo
porque están como jugando el mismo papel
así que bueno yo lo veo de esa manera el
ángulo inferior derecho es igual al
ángulo inferior derecho
así que ángulos correspondientes son
iguales entonces lo escribo aquí ángulos
correspondientes son
son iguales es mi notación abreviada y
bueno en sí ya sabemos todo lo
importante pero si quieres brincar te un
paso también sabemos que ángulos
alternos internos son iguales y aquí me
refiero yo con algunos internos internos
como puedes ver en el dibujo los ángulos
internos son los ángulos que están uno
más cerca del otro cierto pero ángulos
internos están en el lado opuesto de la
transversal aunque tal vez pueda sonar
un poco complicado de esta manera así
que bueno son los ángulos alternos
internos son iguales pero entonces este
ángulo naranja y este ángulo rosa son
ángulos alternos internos y de hecho ya
probamos ya lo y ya lo probamos ya
dijimos que que este ángulo xy este
ángulo x acá el naranja y el rosa son
iguales el ángulo x es igual al ángulo x
así que estos son ángulos alternos
internos esta xy esta x esta x
esta x esta x también son algunos
alternos internos son iguales está allí
y está ayer también son algunos alternos
internos de hecho ya lo probamos ya
probamos que son iguales y finalmente el
ángulo bueno el último término que tú
vas a ver en algún en algún libro de
geometría son los ángulos alternos
externos
estos ángulos también miden lo mismo
esos ángulos son algunos que están están
más alejados
y están en el lado opuesto de la
transversal con respecto a las paralelas
entonces un ejemplo de eso son esta xy
esta x de acá abajo están están las
afueras de las líneas paralelas y en el
lado opuesto de la transversal así que
bueno ese es otro ejemplo y ahora bien
vamos con lo siguiente porque
simplemente son palabras elegantes
espero ya tienes algo de intuición de lo
que yo hablo ángulos correspondientes es
lo más importante todo además sale
directo de los ángulos que se forman
entre las líneas paralelas y la
transversal pero ángulos alternos
externos son este ángulo y este ángulo
ajá luego los otros ángulos exteriores
son ésta
y esta otra de abajo también son iguales
y si sabes eso ya sabes todo lo que
debes saber respecto a líneas paralelas
ahora lo último que te enseñaré para
poder jugar el juego de la geometría es
simplemente que los ángulos internos de
un triángulo suman 180 eso es como es
algo básico que debes saber y ve allá de
ahí en adelante bueno todo además es es
trivial así que bueno no no no tan
trivial voy a dibujar que un triángulo y
digamos que este ángulo mide x este
ángulo mide y este otro ángulo mide z
sabemos que los ángulos internos de un
triángulo x grados más allá grados más
eta grados
la suma es igual a 180 grados entonces
si yo te digo que eso es igual a no sé
digamos que este es igual a 30 grados y
es igual a 70 grados y entonces z es
igual a cuántos grados
tenemos que 30 grados más 70 grados más
z es igual a 180
en maceta es igual a 180 restamos 100 de
ambos lados y obtenemos que z es igual a
80 grados entonces ya con esto ya con
esto ya aprendimos creo que ya estamos
listos para iniciar el juego de la
geometría del juego de los ángulos
entonces bueno ahora sí va a comenzar a
la diversión aquí y bueno espero verte
en el próximo vídeo nos vemos pronto
bye